we're nearly a year now into this
pandemic and things like zoom calls have
become a part of our lives almost every
day
but all those calls can get exhausting
there's a new study from stanford it's
proving that so much video conferencing
is leading to what's called zoom fatigue
those who zoom every day now
say it feels like they are working more
than ever before
and so you don't have that you know this
kind of nice breaks to even get away
you're
you're constantly in front of the
computer jumping from one meeting to the
next
and it can be very exhausting and
turning yeah you got to make sure you're
on mute make sure your video's off
stanford says there's four reasons for
that fatigue prolonged intense eye
contact
seeing yourself during video chats a
lack of overall movement
and all of us working harder to read
nonverbal cues many say they are trying
to fight that fatigue by taking time to
go outside
using those blue light glasses or even
meditating yeah you've got to get away
from the screen for a while